hi everyone and welcome to a Sephora's
I'm serene and I'm Ed yes so jess is
amazing and you sounds ridiculous yes I
actually got the entire office sick I
think it's been a delayed reaction bit
just sorry well I'm glad you're here at
least to take the fall yes so Ed's
filling in today for us and Edmund what
game I have picked a game called
betrayer
it is a first-person kind of minimal I
should hide my phone God horror
action-adventure I guess but more
significantly it was developed by a
company whose employees are made up of
people who used to work at monolith who
of course did feel Wow okay this color
scheme is not what I used yeah so this
is kind of a striking thing about it
obviously they let you kind of change it
to your tastes
oh okay so but I think I think it's
scary and by the way basically headshots
hit the weak point to do bonus damage if
it's just an innocent
NPC waiting to talk to you you want to
kill that's true that is fair so let's
sneak up on him and see how he does what
are the odds that this guy's friendly he
looks human
he looks so he's a conquistador and he's
quite well on it
well should I just tap on the shoulder
like hey dude hello hello oh wow it is
that a chance for some reason this
little knife just like I could hear the
[ __ ] on his armor this is the 17th
century everything's made out of ten
prong way you need to destroy the crate
to get stuff inside
a musket load okay so muskets tomahawks
and bows and arrows in those Oh
that did not sound like a human man oh
it's a the only Nash and n-bomb that's
not a clue dragons that's just an
outright telling you it's what I do the
belch I mean about me it's not oh oh now
we've gone full-on silent mode out yeah
dude your friendly ghost is like Casper
okay I can hear things you did before
okay Wow there we go okay thanks to say
I was holding your head talking about
our son oh [ __ ] I was speaking to a
wraith she's wearing no pants she's also
not wearing shoes okay okay so for some
reason all these god so should I feel
like they die to one knife slash so you
know oh okay so this is okay this is
getting this escalated quickly
okay down to 50 health already how did
he see me maybe he sees you in red like
how you say yes that's quite possible
do I don't want to try to find out what
the hell that was maybe just long-range
Shh oh yeah well you did account nicely
done
Oh y'all you found Toby's helmet oh you
son-of it
okay okay I see a diamond tier now and
it's not showing so that's what Henry
and then there's another time it's I'm
gonna head towards oh yeah these bushes
okay that's the thing is that a woman is
not a go sir said what is this something
in his fans oh I think oh okay I should
have made a move time to GTFO Oh explain
it into many burdens
what's that gonna go to Wars you know
jesus prayed and didn't he just like
fall from the sky
I was thinking burst out of the ground
like that makes more sense
like right now his head's too wavy you
in the right track you do you think yeah
just go around cleansing corruption
cleansing the land of corruption
ossification
why does not sound okay let's not be
silly anymore I say at the ground okay
so there are a lot of enemies that
before and there's a big boss guy who I
was stupid enough to try and merely mind
melee to death
I think how the [ __ ] do they see me I
guess you were loud I think they don't
know where you are I stand corrected
I'll wait okay two for the price of one
hey I stand corrected
quick the back of his helmet always
friends turn around great this is this
is an effective tactic I must say all
right like the strange man bear pig
sound that was betrayal that up yourself
on Steam if you are so inclined
am i off it and yes thank you very much
everyone for joining me today thank you
and we'll be back next week at the same
time hopefully Jess will be in good
health again thanks very much let us
know what you thought about the game in
the comments or in the chat and on the
Twitter hashtag HOH live and if there's
any particular games you'd like to see
us play next week as well do let us know
thanks everyone's guys